SIERRA: Hey, everyone. So, even though Why
It Matters is moving onto other topics,
there's still a lot of questions about COVID-19,
and a great place to find information is a
new site from the Council called ThinkGlobal
Health. It features some incredible reporting
and they're doing a ton of fascinating work
on the pandemic. There's a lot of conflicting
information out there. And, along with the
CDC and WHO websites, ThinkGlobal Health is
a really great way to get grounded and to
begin understanding what's going on. So,
check it out - ah, thank ya!
ECONOMY: I will relate that interesting
story, the president of Kazakhstan,
actually visited a company called Hikvision.
It’s another one that provides surveillance
technology. He visited their office in China.
And he saw how with one click on a person's face,
you could get that person's school history,
work history, financial situation -
SIERRA: Wow.
ECONOMY: And, wait for it, how did this
person spend his or her leisure time. So,
where did this person go to have fun? Did
you go to the movies? Did you stop by the
bank? Did you go to the post office? Were you
hanging out with friends? Did you participate
in a protest? And his reaction after seeing
all of this was, "we need this technology."
SIERRA: Oh. That's not where
I thought the story was going.
SIERRA: This is probably not the first time you’re
hearing about China’s surveillance technology.
And that’s because it gets a lot of
coverage. It’s like a Black-Mirror episode,
it gives us visions of a dystopian future.
But this technology, and the eagerness of
some countries to begin implementing it,
is only a small part of a
much bigger story about China.
Through its Belt and Road initiative, China is in
the process of building and funding infrastructure
projects across the globe, and loaning vast sums
of money in the developing world. Some observers
argue that as it does this, China is also
exporting its authoritarian model of government,
and eroding democratic norms that many of
us take for granted. Others say that China
is simply taking business opportunities where
it sees them, and providing countries with an
alternative to a global order that
has gone unchallenged for decades.
The debate comes down to one question
- how will we choose to view China
as they pour money into hospitals,
ports, and roads around the world?
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It Matters.
Today, is China exporting authoritarianism?
ECONOMY: I think the most important
thing to understand about China's
foreign policy over the past 10 years or
so is that it really has been transformed.
This is Elizabeth Economy. She is a senior fellow
and director for Asia studies here at the Council.
She is also a distinguished visiting fellow
at Stanford University's Hoover Institution.
ECONOMY: You know, beginning in about
2008, with the global financial crisis,
China's, you know, hosting the Olympics. These are
really moments that defined in the minds of
many Chinese leaders that China was rising.
Douglas Paal: The Chinese have many
goals for these Olympics one of them
was to announce to the world that
China is back after 200 bad years.
DW News: China’s economy has grown
faster than that of any other major
country... The Asian giant has now grown into one
of the most important export markets for
manufacturers from all over the world.
Mark Schwartz: This is a period
of historic change in China.
There haven’t been many periods
in history as fascinating as this.
ECONOMY: So there was a real sense within
China for the first time that they had
always expected that at some point, China
was going to surpass the United States. But
maybe that time was coming sooner than they had
anticipated. But what really has changed the game,
on the ground has been Xi Jinping.
Everything for Xi Jinping is under the
sort of mantra of the great rejuvenation
of the Chinese nation. And it is a call
for reclaiming a much greater degree of
centrality for China on the global stage.
SIERRA: Xi Jinping became China’s
president in 2013. Some observers
have called him the most powerful
Chinese leader since Mao Zedong.
ECONOMY: Look, I think there
are any number of objectives,
and we can find them all in Xi Jinping's writings
and speeches. But fundamentally, what I think Xi
Jinping is attempting to do, is simply to
make the world safe for authoritarianism.
Jessica CHEN WEISS:
Xi Jinping is a dictator, but dictators still
have to answer to domestic constituents.
SIERRA: This is Jessica Chen Weiss.
Associate Professor of Government at Cornell,
and a leading expert on Chinese politics. She
has a different take on China’s expansion,
one that sees it as being less
offensive and more defensive.
CHEN WEISS: China is concerned about a whole
lot of different risks. Some of them domestic
and others, ones that sort of emanate from
abroad and you know, sparks that might,
you know, start the prairie fire and bring
down the Chinese government. And my take is
that, you know, it's overriding purpose
is to continue to make a world safe for
the Chinese Communist Party to survive
at home. So this is a world that's safe
for autocracy to coexist alongside democracy
in the international space. So it's not been
as ideological I think in its foreign
policy as some have made it out to be.
SIERRA: So China is trying to find
a way to sort of fit in with a world
that might not be comfortable
with its model of government?
CHEN WEISS: Yeah. It's tried to make space for
its form of government to be regarded as one
that can continue to exist that is legitimate.
That democracy isn't the only form of government,
so to speak. And so this has made it easier
for other authoritarian states to survive.
SIERRA: Whether offensive or defensive,
evidence of China’s expansion can be
read about every day in the news. And if
China is exporting authoritarianism then
a big part of how they’re doing it is through
something called the Belt and Road Initiative.
PBS NewsHour: China’s Belt
and Road Initiative is the
most expensive infrastructure project in history.
PBS NewsHour: 2,000 years ago the ancient
silk road helped China spread goods, ideas,
and culture all the way to Europe.
Today, China aspires to recreate a
maritime silk road of ports and an
economic belt across 70 countries.
ECONOMY: So, Belt and Road Initiative is really
Xi Jinping's calling card. And at the beginning,
it was really an effort to export
overcapacity, right? China had kind of
built up its own infrastructure, to the point
where there wasn't that much left to do. But
it had big cement industries and hydropower
companies and, you know, lots of coal-fired
power plant knowledge and it wanted to export
that. Second, he wanted to connect these poor
parts of the country to external markets. The
coastal part of the country is really well off,
but much of the interior parts of the country
are very poor. So this was an opportunity to
look westward, to extend China's reach, first in
terms of hard infrastructure, ports, pipelines,
you know, railroads, highways, then the digital
Belt and Road, so E-commerce, satellite systems,
fiber optic cables. Initially maybe 60 countries,
you know, through Asia, the Middle East, Europe,
and Africa, but now through the entire world.
The investment is actually smaller than many
people expect. You kind of hear this number
of a trillion dollars in Chinese investment.
How are we ever gonna compete? The reality is
that investment levels are closer to $12 to
$15 billion on an annual basis over the past, say
six years. What China really does is lend money.
CBC News - The National: You’re
saying China essentially loaned
money to itself to do work in another
country - Well, that is what it did.
PBS NewsHour: Countries can lose sovereignty
and China and gain assets. Sri Lanka had
to hand over a port when it couldn’t
afford debt payments to a Chinese bank.
ECONOMY:
It lends buckets of money to countries. And it
expects that those countries when it lends that
money will use Chinese labor, will use Chinese
products. So this is a great deal for China.
SIERRA: Right. I was gonna
say, what's the trade-off here?
ECONOMY: Right. It’s win-win, China
wins twice. So if you look at pretty
much any Belt and Road country, any country
that's been hosting Belt and Road projects,
you will find that there are some fairly
significant protests on the ground. In fact,
even among China's closest friends like Pakistan
and Cambodia, you will see that the people are
protesting these projects. You know why? Because
China does bring in its own labor for many of
these projects. So the people themselves aren't
realizing the benefits. There's also the export
of China's way of doing business. So there's a
lack of transparency in the tendering process for
these deals. You know, there are environmental and
social ramifications are not really accounted for.
CHEN WEISS: The belt and road
initiative is one of Xi Jinping
signature international initiatives. I
tend to side with those that see this as
more of a bumper sticker slogan. One
that Xi Jinping is proud to hold up,
but there is a lot of diversity in terms of
the different projects that make up the belt
and road. And it isn't one sort of single grand
strategy that we can easily put our finger on.
SIERRA: So it seems like a lot of this
comes down to motives and goals. How
can we really know what China or
Xi Jinping's ultimate motives are?
ECONOMY: It's actually really easy to know what
Xi Jinping's motives are because he has published
already two books of his own speeches, and it is
very clear what he desires. And it's all about
this great rejuvenation of the Chinese nation.
He's very ambitious. He talks about China leading
the reform of the global governance system. He
talks about the necessity of the dissolution of
the US-led alliance system. There is really,
no hidden, you know, meaning or purpose to Xi
Jinping. He is very upfront about where he sees
China in the future. Where he wants China to be
in the future, the place that he wants China to
hold, on the global stage. So I don't think we
need to be trying to divine motives. I think he's
very, very clear about what those motives are.
SIERRA: The United States has also tried to
shape the way other countries develop and
govern in the past. So how are China's
methods and goals different from ours?
ECONOMY: Well, in many respects, what
China is doing, is exactly the same.
I mean, the effort to train officials, to
provide guidance on laws and regulations,
to help support through technology the system
of governance that you are, helping to develop,
all of these things are the exact same things
that the United States does. Personally,
I just tend to think that, you know, we're
promoting democracy at least ostensibly. And
they're promoting a system of authoritarianism.
So I don't actually see that much difference in
the methods that we use except when we look to
the really coercive methods, but in terms of
capacity building, we're doing many of the same
things just with different ultimate objectives.
SIERRA: So, what exactly is China’s model
of government? Do some Googling and you’ll
see a whole bunch of phrases. From a unitary,
one-party, socialist republic to a Communist
party-led state - there’s no shortage of debate.
But Liz has a simpler way of describing it.
ECONOMY: I think a good way of capturing the
Chinese governance system is to say that it's
basically a system of authoritarian capitalism.
It is a variant of that. Yes, there is a Chinese
Communist Party, which you won't find in any
other country, of course, but at its heart,
it really is just a single-party state, in which
the party exerts an enormous amount of control
over society, over the, you know, political
system, over the media, over the internet.
SIERRA: So is China exporting
this model of government?
CHEN WEISS: I don't see China as exporting this
model of government. There is some emulation
that may be going on, by countries that look
to China’s example admiringly and want to
copy elements of it. And there's also some
diffusion going on where China is literally
selling some of the technologies that, including
surveillance technology, that China has developed
to monitor its citizens at home and is happy
to sell that overseas for profit. China is,
you know, seeking to go places where it serves
its economic and political interests. China tends
to work with whatever countries, whatever
forms of government are that are out there.
ECONOMY: Well, this, of course, is
a big debate. But I come down pretty
clearly on the side of - yes, in fact, they are.
It's not about exporting the Chinese Communist
Party, but it is about exporting elements of
this authoritarian capitalist system, you
know, very much in the same way that the
United States and other market democracies,
export, elements, of their system, so too is
China now exporting elements, doing training
activities, and other things, that support the
development of authoritarian capitalist systems.
SIERRA: One way to start unpacking the debate is
to take a look at the two basic ways that
China is helping other nations govern their
citizens. The first is by literally sending
them to school. Officials and legislators
from around the world are traveling to China
to attend trainings where they can learn from
China’s experience. Officials from at least 36
countries have attended these trainings so far.
ECONOMY: It's about helping them develop and
pass laws and regulations, that again, support,
this kind of authoritarian model. Right? So
you're going to have internet laws that are
designed to constrain opportunities for the
free flow of information. How do you manage
civil society? How do you control the media?
There are all sorts of training opportunities,
but there are also other things. Training
opportunities for poverty alleviation,
other elements of the China model, developing
infrastructure, you know, the heavy role of the
state in state-owned enterprises. How do
you develop those? How do you use them to
advance your economic and political interests?
Beyond that, you have training that is simply
like training for the Justice ministers or
economic ministers or defense ministers.
SIERRA: The other broad element is that
China, and private Chinese companies,
are providing tech to monitor, censor, and
control citizens. The most well-known part
of this is called “safe city technology”,
you know, the tech that really hooked the
president of Kazakhstan. It’s a mixture
of tried-and-true security cameras and
cutting edge facial recognition that has made
China the global capital of surveillance.
Wall Street Journal: To be in Xinjiang means
being checked every day, multiple times a day.
BBC News: China’s sophisticated and controversial
data surveillance system is used
to track citizens on and off-line.
ABC News In-depth: A personal scorecard for 1.4
billion citizens - rewards for good
behavior and punishments for bad.
FRANCE 24 English: The QR codes have now become
the passports that allow Chinese people to move
around, to get into a shop, one must show
a green health code proving good health.
CHEN WEISS: So one of the areas that China
has been kind of a leader is in this sort of
AI-powered surveillance. It's something that China
has developed extensively to use at home. And
that's been particularly on display in Xinjiang,
where China has, you know, interned more than
a million Uyghurs and other ethnic minorities
and what many have called concentration camps.
But again, China is not the only purveyor
of safe city technology. And in other cases,
safe cities are seen as, you know,
effective ways to reduce crime as well.
ECONOMY: So in terms of the
whole safe city initiative,
there are a couple of things to
bear in mind. First, you know,
the idea behind safe cities I think could be
attractive to any country. Right? What police
department wouldn't be pleased with the idea
that you could catch a crime in progress or
identify a criminal within, you know, minutes
of that person having committed some crime?
SIERRA: Right.
ECONOMY: That is attractive. Right? So
what we're really talking about is how
far the system can be taken and how it
can be turned into an abuse of people's
rights. And I think here's where everything
starts to become a little more concerning.
Huawei for example, which is a major provider
of safe city technology, has said that it is
providing this technology, you know, in over 200
cities globally. But what it might include would
be the television cameras, with the closed circuit
TVs, the control centers, the data processing,
and then other things that might be included
will be things like drones. And then Huawei will
sometimes provide the training, for example,
in Uganda. They have trained almost 1,000
Ugandans on how to do E-governance and how to
manage the sort of safe city technology. Again,
for countries that have authoritarian
leanings, you know, the opportunity,
to be able to have that level of detail
on every single one of your citizens -
SIERRA: Right.
ECONOMY: To know, you know, with
whom people are meeting, and again,
are they participating in a protest? Are
they putting things on the internet that
are anti-government in some way? This is
very attractive to governments like that.
CHEN WEISS: Most countries around the world
use some kind of surveillance technology
and that China is only one of many suppliers.
And many countries rely on multiple different
suppliers to source this technology. So, you know,
Saudi Arabia for example, uses technology from
China to surveil its citizens. But they also are
buying technology from UK and US-based companies.
SIERRA: So why do you think it is that the
Chinese technology is what people are questioning?
CHEN WEISS: It’s an important question. I think
it's easier to say that the problems that arise in
the world stem from things that other bad actors
are doing. It's harder to look within ourselves
and recognize that we are struggling with many
of the same problems including ubiquitous,
digital surveillance. Difficulty figuring out
what's the appropriate model for regulating
the internet, sort of respecting privacy, but
also the kind of the free flow of information.
SIERRA: The combination of know-how
and equipment seems to be the footing
for tech-driven authoritarianism, and
China has found willing partners in
authoritarian regimes across
the world. At the same time,
China is seeking to use its clout to shift the
conversation even in powerful Democratic nations.
ECONOMY: A second is really exporting the China
model through, international institutions, right?
So trying to make sure that Chinese values around
things like human rights, or internet sovereignty,
or even its positions on things like Taiwan or the
South China Sea, are reflected in international
institutions. Right? You know, the United Nations,
so you can see over the past several years,
they've become very active in trying to
change the language around human rights.
To be more explicit, you know, we recognize human
rights as inalienable, right? We are all born
with our inalienable rights. China says rights
are granted and can be taken away by the state.
SIERRA: That's different.
ECONOMY: Right? Exactly. It's very different.
ECONOMY: And inalienable rights means the right
to free speech. Right? Means you're gonna have
things like the free media, the right to protest.
These are all things that are antithetical to the
China model, to an authoritarian political
system, which is about constraining the
rights of individuals to act independently.
Beyond that China is looking for support,
on the global stage. So when you know, the
United States and other countries, you know,
in Western Europe, Australia, tried to put forward
a resolution condemning Chinese detention of, you
know, a million and a half Uyghurs in labor and
re-education camps, in Xinjiang Autonomous Region,
China managed to get upwards of 50 countries to
say that China's human rights practices are great.
SIERRA: This international support is even
more shocking when you take a closer look at
China’s record. Global rights watchdogs cite a
broad increase in violations under Xi Jinping.
The most obvious case is the government’s
persecution of Muslims in Xinjiang, where many
Islamic practices have been banned, and where
at least one million people are being held in
political re-education camps. Then there’s China’s
unprecedented system of mass surveillance, and its
strict repression of free speech, both online and
in political hot spots like Tibet and Hong Kong.
Those who advocate for human rights in China face
imprisonment and enforced disappearance, as do
advocates for women and LGBTQ communities. Human
Rights Watch says that China’s ability to erode
international norms, represents an “existential
threat to the rights of people worldwide.”
ECONOMY: So I think, you know, when it comes
to dealing with criticism from countries about,
Chinese behavior, the Chinese government very much
looks to these countries that it is supporting
through Belt and Road projects and in other ways,
to stand up behind it and give it its support.
SIERRA: Right. So friends who will
vote for you when the time comes.
ECONOMY: Absolutely. And frankly, just look
at what happened with Coronavirus. You know,
you saw Pakistan, Cambodia, Nigeria, all these
countries refuse to repatriate their own citizens
from Wuhan. Right, which was the epicenter of this
Coronavirus as a statement of their friendship to
China. So I think that's the type of, sort of
reward, that China really values, as coming out
of these sorts of, you know, capacity building
and economic projects that it's been doing.
SIERRA: Right. And that's not
even long term. That's right now,
they're already seeing the result of that.
ECONOMY: Oh, absolutely. So that's the
second element of China's export of its,
of its model. And then the third is a little bit
different. Because when you think about export,
of course, you think about having a willing
consumer. Right? You have somebody who's
importing it on the other end. But in some
cases, China uses the leverage of its market,
right? Because it has a huge market to
try to coerce other countries or actors
to accept it's model or elements of its model.
And I think a really great example of this,
was here in the United States, with the case of
the Houston Rockets General Manager, Daryl Morey.
Trevor Noah: General manager of the Houston
Rockets posted a tweet in support of
the pro-democracy protests in Hong Kong.
CNN: Despite his apologies, several Chinese
businesses are now suspending ties with the
Houston Rockets over that tweet. The NBA’s
response is also raising questions over the
lengths that businesses in the US
have to go, and are willing to go,
to stay in favor with the Chinese government
for access to the lucrative Chinese market.
ECONOMY: And when he tweeted, you know,
“Fight for freedom stand with Hong Kong.”
SIERRA: Right.
ECONOMY: You know, China responded by, you know,
canceling all the broadcasts of the NBA games,
all of the Houston Rockets licensing deals
were pulled for, you know, their merchandising
in China. And what came out of that afterward was
not just simply the effort by China to use, again,
it's market to pressure the NBA. But a statement
in the People's Daily that said, essentially,
that when people are talking about things related
to sovereignty or social stability, these things
do not fall within the purview of free speech. So
imagine that here's this government in China, that
is trying to tell people in the United States and
elsewhere, right? There's a whole range of issues
that you in the United States and other countries
cannot discuss publicly because they offend us.
SIERRA: Right.
ECONOMY: So it's a very subtle and coercive
way, really, of exporting their models, because
they're basically saying - you can't talk about
Taiwan, Hong Kong or anything else we decide -
SIERRA: Right.
ECONOMY: You know, relates
to our social stability.
SIERRA: So, China’s newfound global economic
power has succeeded in getting dozens of
countries to vote in its favor at the UN.
And it has also pushed democratic nations
to concede to censorship in order to
gain access to its enormous market.
SIERRA: What do you think that
China wants to get out of these
efforts in the long term? What's the goal here?
CHEN WEISS: Well ultimately, as I said, I
think, you know, China wants to become a
strong and resilient global power. But China also
is, you know, very much, sort of going where the
opportunities present themselves. Where,
you know, is Chinese assistance in demand
and where there's an opportunity, you know,
left by, the lack of, competitive alternatives.
SIERRA: So, I mean, do you
see this as just sort of a
good business opportunity that they're taking?
CHEN WEISS: Largely I do see
it that way. It's partly that,
it’s also I think an effort to secure
access to resources in the event of
global disruption. Markets, of course, are
important, but, you know, China, I think,
recognizes that they can't always be relied upon
in the event of conflict. And so, you know, China
has also invested strategically,
in developing those relationships.
ECONOMY: So I am quite concerned about the
ability of China to export its own values,
its own conception of what is allowed
under free speech into the United States.
SIERRA: Do you think that China's efforts
are already changing norms around the world?
ECONOMY: So, I think there's no doubt that China's
already transforming international norms. You can
see it when countries are supporting China,
when China rejects rulings by the Permanent
Court of Arbitration in the South China Sea. And
it has scores of countries stand up for it there,
or it has, many countries stand up, behind its
behavior in Xinjiang autonomous region. You know,
the Belt and Road Initiative has now been
put into more than 20 different UN agencies.
Right? So you have UN officials, traveling to
Africa and saying you should participate in the
Belt and Road. I think there are many respects
in which China already is changing the discourse,
and is finding ways to ensure that international
institutions and other countries are accepting
its norms, its values, its policy priorities,
simply because it is such a big economic player.
SIERRA: Are you worried that all of
this playing defense against China
will lead to escalating tensions?
ECONOMY: Frankly speaking, yes, it's entirely
possible that we'll have escalating tensions,
we already have escalating tensions. My hope is
that by pushing back, that what we're going to
do is crack things open, so that we can actually
have negotiations, right? So by going out there
with sort of this higher bar, in terms of
the standards for infrastructure projects,
that that will actually entice China to raise
its standards. It's not about preventing China
from doing infrastructure globally. It's
about ensuring that the infrastructure
that is developed is done at the highest
standards. Right? You want fair competition,
right? For multinationals to participate. But
you also want the environmental standards and
the labor standards to be ones that serve the
interests of the people in the host countries.
SIERRA: What do you think the risks
are of exaggerating the threat that
China poses to the US’s place in the world?
CHEN WEISS: I think there are two big risks of
exaggerating the danger that China poses. First,
is that it is likely to turn the US-China
competition into one that's life or death by
convincing Chinese even more than they are already
that there is no place for China to lead in the
world. And that second, it is dangerous because
it's more likely to isolate the United States.
There are very few countries
around the world that want to make
a choice between China and the United States. And
they aren't likely to take sides. And if they do,
we, in the United States may or
may not come out ahead in that.
SIERRA: So it could become a self-fulfilling
prophecy if we keep pushing that narrative?
CHEN WEISS: Right. The United States competition
with China does not need to be a cold war,
but I think the policies of, you know,
existential competition, if framed that way,
may still have the counterproductive
effect of actually bringing one about.
SIERRA: What do you say to people who will say
that China isn't necessarily playing offense,
they're just trying to make the world
safe for their system of government?
ECONOMY: I would say that it is a
distinction without a difference that,
the best defense is a good offense, that
Xi Jinping has talked very directly about
the need for China to lead in the reform of the
global governance system. And that if protecting
China means that China is going to change norms
around human rights, around internet governance,
around freedom of navigation, around free
trade, around standard setting, you know,
for infrastructure projects globally, that
that to me fundamentally is not simply about
protecting China's interests. It is about
changing the norms of the rest of the world
to align with those of China. And that
is fundamentally an offensive strategy.